hello everybody time for another movie
retrospective here's another one that's
been requested a couple of times and I
noticed that they had it free on to be
so I thought now was a good time to do
it as any and since we'd already we've
already we've only done one Ken Russell
film which was altered states which we
did a few months ago so I decided it's
time to do another one this is kind of
one of his lesser-known ones this is
layer of the white worm yeah now this
movie like most of Ken Russell's other
movies is batshit and saying yeah I
remember when this came out yeah I had
seen I had seen it but I forgot all
about it I mostly just remember the
cover of the damn VHS it is a very
striking cover I did say with Amanda
Donna
I want it coming out of the basket I was
always getting it confused with like
serpent serpent in the rainbow I guess
because the titles are kind of similar
yeah like they're good I forgot
everything about it so watching it again
was like seeing a brand new movie there
was the only thing that I really
remembered that there that I clicked
with me were the hallucination scenes
yes they were very very Ken Russell II
yeah and much like his other ones and
actually kind of some of the UM you know
weird visions in this were kind of like
the ones in altered states where it was
kind of like because he uses like a lot
of religious symbolism it's like you
know people like Jesus stuff and
religion
evil [ __ ] yeah and if you guys have seen
like his older movie the devil's which
was all about which was all about nuns
and religious stuff and everything
whereas this one was more like a
Christian versus pagan type of thing
yeah I came out in 1988
now what ended up happening with this
this was a thing where Ken Russell he
was um I guess he was under contract to
like Wester on pictures or something and
it was like a three picture deal he had
made gothic which came out in 1986 which
actually we should do that one too cuz I
really like that movie so he had made
that and that was kind of successful and
he wanted to make a sequel to women in
love I think which he would go on to
make later on but they said so in
between it's like if you make a horror
movie in between that then we'll give
you the funding to do the sequel to
women in love
so he agreed to do that now he was a big
fan of Dracula and apparently had
written a screen treatment of Dracula
that never got made or whatever so he
wanted to do something along that he
didn't want to do Dracula but he wanted
to do something along that line so
somebody suggested to him I guess it was
a friend of his or something was like
hey why don't you do one of you know
Bram Stoker's like lesser-known novels
and loaned him layer of the white worm
which I think was Bram Stoker's last
novel that he wrote before he died I
think it came out in 1911 now I have not
read the entire book I've listened to
some of the audiobook um it's pretty
much you know it's not universally
reviled but a lot of people are like you
know compared to how awesome Dracula was
this one was kind of a step down you
know cuz maybe Bram Stoker was like who
lost his mojo he's getting too old at
this point or something like that it
seemed it's a very vampiric story but it
seemed very clunky and it's just seemed
like I don't know like I started
listening to like the first five or six
chapters and I couldn't really get all
that much into it and then you know once
it gets to chapter five or six and
everything's n-word this n-word that and
I was just kind of like okay I'm out you
know what I mean it's like you thought
HP Lovecraft was bad but yeah so that's
that was kind of that but what he
decided to do like Ken Russell didn't
wasn't really crazy about the book
either but he did like the idea of it of
like a pagan snake cult that was still
operating in rural Britain because he's
like this is where he lived at the time
so he thought it was like a neat idea
that maybe there would be this like
creepy cult like from ancient times that
was still like lurking around like just
in these [ __ ] rural English towns
where no one would think about it so he
basically just took the kind of bones of
the story and moved it up to the modern
day and put it in derbyshire I think is
where he said it and kind of ran with it
from there now I think in the book there
was um like an aristocratic lady like
that was the villain that just like in
the movie although there was also a dude
they were like a pair so because I think
like the whole point of the book
like the aristocrats like sucking dry
the working class and the common man and
stuff because you know bram stoker being
Irish she was kind of like he had a lot
of like anti English stuff what again is
work so it he kind of went a lot into
that in this one Ken Russell said I
didn't really care about the guy villain
because he wasn't that interesting but
he did think that the woman was
interesting the one that like fed the
snake and everything like that so he
basically made her the main the main
villain and I think that was probably a
good idea because she's easily the best
part of this now I will say I don't know
if I would call this it's a horror movie
in the sense that it has horror elements
but Ken Russell he has come out saying
that he's like I did intend this to be a
comedy also and he's like and I feel
like a lot of people didn't really get
that at the time even though if you
watch it now it's mention yeah it's
really really funny in the way that like
an Oscar Wilde plays but it's like you
know the repartee between the characters
is like really witty and yeah there's
like ridiculous situations and yeah I
don't know anything about the wrote the
original story I don't think it's really
relevant to the movie um if it is
whatever I'm just you look at the movie
it's a damn vampire movie yeah there's a
lot of there's a lot of crossover in
this a worm when they talk about worm
they're talking about like the Germanic
version of a worm a dragon yeah you know
Dracula was his father was in the order
of the Dragon and Draco and you know
they're there so there's there's senile
constant crossover between a dragons and
and vampires you know and that's what
this is it's it's kind of like a dragon
or a snake like dragon and it makes
vampires and the ones that serve it are
kind of like vampires they bite you and
you turn it away and you turn it what's
that same [ __ ] thing you know Dracula
I guess you could say there's more of
like a wolf or a vampire bat vampire
these are more like snake vampires or
dragon vampires yeah so this is almost
like a vampire movie that isn't it's
like a rebooted usually called a vampire
me yeah it's like a reboot of the of the
vampire genre yeah you know your your
rebooting vampires
just you know off the top I thought it
was a great movie though this is not a
movie of its time it's just not this is
not an 80s movie this is like a 60s
British movie or a 70s British it comes
across like a like a hammer film on acid
yeah or like everywhere sexual a lot of
nudity in it lots of cool [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] hallucinations it also
kind of reminded me of a Tom who of the
doctor Baker
Doctor Who episode without Doctor Who
when it's resting when he could have
been Doctor Who at any minute
well this movie Peter Capaldi is in it
when he was young playing Angus Flint
who was a Scottish archaeologist and he
was actually one he played doctor who
later on oh I didn't know that so there
you go yeah it is so baby that's why
they gave me that vibe kind of reminded
me of you know like Doctor Who and the
Loch Ness monster that yeah mister who
and you know it just was like Doctor Who
movie it was kind of and they so they
used like an actual apparently like an
actual real like British legend the
Lampton worm so he wanted to kind of tie
that in with the vampire thing like I
said this is essentially a vampire story
because you know the woman who's like
the the feeder of the white worm
she's um you know snake-like but she has
fangs she has like you know creepy eyes
she can hypnotize people um you know she
can if she bites you it like passes on
and all this other stuff but technically
it is a vampire movie I guess yeah so
alright so like I said so Peter Capaldi
is in this when he's very young looking
like cuz we kind of made jokes and he
was like looking like he goes barreled
rapist yeah who did kind of look like
because he had like the big fluffy hair
and everything also a very early role
for Hugh Grant this was actually before
he got real big Hugh Grant with a
unibrow he did have a little bit of a
brown brown like it wasn't all the way
across but there was like a little bit
thing he was like paint yeah he's like
baby Hugh Grant and like baby Peter
Capaldi or and they did a good job all
the acting is good innit he played I
mean I I feel like
we're Hugh Grant he always gets I mean I
guess it's because of the voice or
whatever but he always gets stuck
playing like these upper class twit
types like it up and [ __ ] which is
exactly what he plays in this he plays
like the lord of the manor which I guess
liked it like I said in the book he
would have also been a bad guy but he
wasn't a bad guy he was a good guy you
meet the dragon lady the dragon lady
shows up she's in this white [ __ ]
coat and a damn white tri-cornered hat I
love that I love her [ __ ] fashion in
this yeah she looked like she looked
like [ __ ] [ __ ] at a man from
[ __ ] standing deliver videos that's
sometimes she started look like Siouxsie
Sioux yeah in her dominatrix outfit it
was good move big old fire boots yeah
[ __ ] be a being sexually predacious
on underage man yeah we were trying to
figure out real like how old boy was cuz
it's like she picks up this guy like
he's into boys yes yeah yeah this little
Boy Scouts want to go back to the youth
hostel yeah and she like talks him into
like coming back to the house cuz you
know what you're bringing in and he's
all wet she's trying to seduce his ass
you know the mean with all this [ __ ]
sexy outfits and stuff and he's not
really responded it's like he doesn't
even notice and Kevin yeah Kevin right
and you know as the audience you're
thinking she's gonna try to scare the
kid but now she was gonna [ __ ] kill
him
kill him and eat him or Sarah feed him
to the [ __ ] Dre yeah because her
whole thing her name is Lady Sylvia
Marsh in the movie they've changed it I
think in the she was called Arabella
something or other in the book but it's
you know the equivalent so she's
basically the guardian of the Lambton
worm the white worm that lives like
underneath the ground it's like you know
what I mean it's kind of like like you
said it's like the Loch Ness monster
kind of thing where I guess like a long
time ago now the the Christian V pagans
stuff that I don't think was in the book
but Ken Russell you know what I said he
loves like his Christian imagery and all
this other kind of stuff so he really
like hit it hard and this one he even
renamed a bunch of the characters like
the two sisters that run Mersey farm are
named Mary and Eve you know everyone has
like biblical names yeah and there's
even a scene where like Amanda Donahoe
he's like the bad
the villain she's like up in a tree like
tempting Eve you know I mean she's like
the snake lady and stuff like that so
it's very very obvious that that serpent
in Genesis right that that's what that's
what he's doing
yeah so apparently what it is is that a
long time ago like thousands of years
ago like when this area was called
Murcia there was a pagan cult that
worshipped this worm or dragon it's like
a big white dragon yeah I mean obviously
this movie came out in 1980s so you know
come on like I said it's free on to be
if you want to watch it watching my war
one gothic is already is on there as
well
which I might do in a little while so I
think that's the only Ken Russell movies
that were on there cuz I want to do the
devil's - but it's like I wish that was
on there but it's not good movies bunch
of lesbian action in it [ __ ] there's all
yeah this is like a very and like I said
like masculine like most Ken Russell
movies this is like it all it's very
like perverse and there's like you know
you get to see Amanda Donahoe naked
painted blue wearing a fit like a metal
like thing with a big huge spike dildo
on it yeah so you know she's doing
checking for virginity yeah it's all
kinds of [ __ ] weird this is the kind
of movie that it is I'm just a great
yeah but yeah like oh man it was it was
you couldn't make a movie like this
today
it's a weird [ __ ] movie it would
cancel this movie I mean like I said all
of Ken Russell's movies are weird and I
said this is even as weirdest one but
this one's pretty weird and like I said
it does have all of this thing where the
vision now one thing that does kind of
weird me out is that so the two sisters
Mary and Eve they live in this at mercy
farm which is like an inn you know what
I mean like people say they have lodgers
and stuff like that and um a year before
their parents had gone missing walking
home from the pub and nobody knows what
happened to them and they just like
vanished off the face of the earth and
so you know so at the start of story
they're kind of dealing with that and
then like Peter Capaldi's character
Angus Flint he's an archaeologist and he
has come there like he's researching
like you know Britain's pagan past and
all this other stuff so he finds a skull
that everyone thinks at first is maybe
it's cold but they're not really sure
what it is I mean you know spoiler alert
it's a big like [ __ ] dragon skull
type of thing so he finds it they're
gonna try and figure out what it is then
they find this kind of mosaic down there
that has like a big white worm around it
and [ __ ] and then it turns out that this
pagan cult was there was a temple there
and at one point like when the
Christians took over they like subsumed
and then like wiped out this most of
this cult and built a nunnery on top of
it and apparently the you know the
adherents of the snake hole were none
too happy about it
so this but the worm has been down there
the whole time now I don't know they
don't really go into lady Sylvia Marsh
because she lives in Temple house and I
don't know how long she's lived there I
don't know because she says she was
immortal yeah and you know what you know
you watch it and you see what they're
doing it's almost like an homage of a
movie called The Hunger yes pretty much
a character like the woman from The
Hunger yeah like how do like Catherine
Deneuve's yeah yeah a stylish [ __ ]
you know upper-class it's witty vampire
chick but she's like a vampire lizard
yeah snake a snake Peyer I thought
somebody else like Raveena said they
said they said snake yes that's really
what they are and she really really um
she really really hates Christianity
because man she's like she's in mercy
farm and she sees like the little cross
oh yeah she doesn't while a music cuz
she'll get mesmerized because you can
charm them like snakes that's that's
actually one is my I mean there's a lot
of really great scenes and it's like I
said don't go in expecting this to be
scary because it's very very campy kind
of but it knows that that's what it is
it's scary in the way that a British 60s
horror movie is scary yeah it does have
like a hammer kind of vibe to it yeah
where it kinda has a macabre and
perverse kind of element to it it
doesn't have jump scares or anything no
it doesn't really have any like body
horror or anything on it
that I remember and there was not really
there was a little bit of gore there was
some gory a little bit but not a lot
it's just some people did get killed and
get bit yeah like it kind of like eaten
Nunchuk I didn't really find it to be an
offensive movie just entertaining it is
like it is very entertaining like I said
it's one of those one weird imagery when
when they get bitten or something the
poison affects them in weird ways to
have these visions and [ __ ] of you'll
see just weird pervert perversity mixed
with Christianity and yeah like I said
there's lakes and Dragons there there's
Jesus up on the cross there's a white
snake around it and there's nuns and
there's like they're all getting raped
by by weights in the night fire and they
weren't nicer by Romans Romans and then
and then like weird things of like that
hot snake fire chick blowing this
[ __ ] spiked phallus it's all bloody
and [ __ ] the thing remember that she's
like blowing it yeah it's like all this
happened on the same screen and it's and
the effects are [ __ ] weird it does
look like an acid trip he does like I
said he does that a lot with that kind
of green-screen collaging kind of thing
he did that altered states as well and I
can't remember I haven't seen The
Devil's in a long time but I think he
does that in that too so he seems to
really like that look and that so to me
that look always looks very Ken Russell
II because I guess he likes because it's
real stuff but the way it's like layered
and because it's a green-screen looks it
looks unreal in a way that like is kind
of unsettling yeah and the people that
are experiencing they're all getting
[ __ ] you know they're they're
debilitating by it yeah there's like
there's a little like there there's a
little [ __ ] spikes dildos going on
everybody um expand going up the thing
and the deal and everything but yeah
it's like like I said this is like a
[ __ ] okay so so you get the two
sisters there and you got your snake
lady who what I'm saying this one
another thing about the movie I gotta
bust in because you know for the guys
out there I got a [ __ ] nip it in the
bud we were the girls good-looking yeah
they were I got one girl nationally they
care yeah yeah yeah what a good yeah
there we go one of them's got this block
this blog little short haircut got this
square head she's pretty cute and then
her sister she's pretty cute too and
then the vampire girl she's pretty cute
it's just you know to me
and then the guy Hugh Grant for the
ladies and then they got oh he gone in
there I guess what he's gotta say yeah
macho Scottish guy who's pissed off at
this [ __ ] upper class kind of
effeminate jock boy played by Hugh Grant
he's kind of he is kind of he's kind of
tough walked off in a way that a [ __ ]
you know jock is tough I guess you could
say but he's [ __ ] just kind of
annoying too because he's just so with
what the British called twee
yeah he's very tweet tweet yeah just you
know to tweet for his own good
he'd get laughed at in the u.s. well I
mean lord of the manor
lord of the manor he knows about you
know the in the movie even though the
the legend in Britain is called the
Lambton worm and he they even have use a
version of the song which is a
traditional live British folk song you
know they do kind of cool like pogs he
kind of yeah but um and the Scottish guy
he gets pissed off at all this tweet us
and tries to [ __ ] stop it and try to
he tries to actually deal with it
directly because they're dealing with a
[ __ ] dragon you know even though mr.
tweeze ancestors was out there killing
Madrid that's what I was just about to
dam it's called damped encasing he's
like Lord bitchin I think he did end up
he did end up killing it the second time
didn't eaten but didn't know it was gone
to kill you I'm gonna call him ego
peter capaldi killed yeah what was the
name of that character Angus Angus
that's right and he was wearing a
[ __ ] kilt yeah they kill and he was
sick and playing bagpipes of [ __ ]
everybody this is like a scene that a
lot of people read they're like this is
how ridiculous and awesome this movie is
there is an actual scene where Peter
Capaldi in a kilt
yeah plays bagpipes to fight over to
charm a vamp like a fat cop who has been
turned into a snake buyer thankfully
yeah and he's like leading them like
around the [ __ ] [ __ ] it doesn't
matter if it's nighttime or daytime they
come on yeah they're not vampires in the
sense that they can't walk around they
can walk around well cuz a snake doesn't
just they don't seem to need to drink
blood either they could just bite you
yeah they weren't drinking blood no they
weren't they were eating food like I
said yeah so I'm not real sure like I
said I don't want to delve too much into
like the the mythology behind it but I
mean Lee
Silvia hurtful deal was she was like the
guardian of the worm and she was the one
she was like looking for virgins to like
feed to it because that's what was his
favorite thing now he did she did feed
like other people to it there weren't
virgins but she would kill them first
and just throw them in there like that's
like the garbage food so I guess the
Virgin's were like the delicacy that he
got every now and better but she said
that she fed the Virgin's to them while
they were alive yes yes I mean the other
one he killed them and then just roam in
there and just like Vicodin yeah and
just like a British movie they delivered
man to [ __ ] it you know they got a
good-looking cast yeah yeah they're you
know what's the English word they were
they did that [ __ ] right
they knew have it in a lot of way
British movies were better than American
movies they actually kind of had people
that acted you know I mean they got
their jobs because they could act in
Hollywood it mostly was depended on who
you were blowing and how much blow you
had that kind of [ __ ] got you into the
movies so they could act and they they
looked good and the movie actually the
special effects of the movie were pretty
cool like the underground scenes to make
it looks pretty good yeah it looks real
good like for 1988
yeah they show the worm like at the
bottom and like you know you can tell
that it's probably like green screen
door it's been there you know whatever
but it still looks cool and it's you're
not talking realism here this this um
you can tell that it's just you can tell
this asset you know that stage isn't
[ __ ] and it is kind of theatrical the
acting is kind of theatrical it's kind
of over the top kind of over the top but
it's kind of all along the spectrum yeah
I was gonna say that one that the two
sisters there's a little over the top to
like the way they talk and stuff now I
think I please correct me if I'm wrong
but Catherine Oxenberg who plays even
this I think I think she's the weird
thing about this is I think she's an
American and they wanted they said well
we need an American actress in this
because of course there has to be an
American and everything or for some
reason and so they put her in there but
then they dubbed her over with a British
accent well I was very sad sometimes you
saw a [ __ ] like that happen because
there is a bunch of contracts in between
studios yeah that's true
the where if you want to make a movie
that you want to release in the United
States there has to be a certain amount
of
American actors in it it's probably
something like that I just thought it
was really weird that it's like they
kind of went out of their way to say we
want an American actor but then they
dubbed her over it was private legal
purposes in a British accent it's pretty
good track xual / unless there was a
different version of it what does she
use to her own voice because you could
very clearly tell that that was not
because this movie was I remember when
it was released in the United States and
people were watching it my friends watch
I watched it and we liked it I just
forgot everything about it yeah I forgot
everything it's one of those ones that
kind of fell through the cracks I feel
like yeah um just because you know Ken
Russell like a lot of people really like
Ken Russell movies but every talks about
altered states or maybe the you know the
Devils or something like that but I feel
like by the time the late 80s had rolled
around you know maybe he didn't get as
much attention as he did like in the 70s
and early 80s maybe um I'm not sure like
I said this isn't my favorite movie of
his but this is one that I think I first
saw it I don't think I saw it in the
theater but I caught it on cable and
there was something about it I just
really cuz I really liked a lot of
British movies anyway and there was
something about it I really liked I
really liked the perversity of it I
really liked like a lot of the really
weird imagery yeah and it wasn't really
perverse by today's standard not really
but like back then it was rage it was
race movie yeah they were getting sexual
and stuff when they shouldn't have been
like after young boys girl won't have a
young boys putting him in the tub I put
a minute playing snakes and my mother
doesn't do this for me that kind of
weird [ __ ] it's like that's what I mean
it's like it's actually it's really
really funny yeah like all the [ __ ] like
she's like cleaning his back like he's
the tow she is like they're her [ __ ]
thigh high a leather boot yeah yeah
we're in like this little awareness like
raw and like oh [ __ ] and then like he's
in that he's not even noticing and he's
just like whatever this is nice like
he's like don't you have doesn't she say
something like don't you have a
girlfriend that does it for you he's
like no my mom doesn't do this for me
there's like 70 she was totally clueless
and she's coming on to him and he's just
like you know
doesn't even Pike passes mine here's
yeah he was just like very guilelessly
this is how this kind of thing happens
yeah you know what's funny about this
and I think I told you this last night
was that I'm not sure about cuz they cuz
her thing is that everything is like
snake light like everything she says has
something he's just like oh I hibernate
in the winter and I do this and the
other thing so she's she makes him
they're laying out on front of the
fireplace like a little pillows and [ __ ]
and they're playing snakes and ladders
now I'm not sure I didn't realize
because in the u.s. if you didn't know
it's chutes and ladders so I thought for
a long time that the snakes and ladders
thing for that movie which is the thing
that they made up for that movie but
then I found out later that no in the UK
it actually is snakes and ladders okay
and not chutes and ladders so I guess
when they adapted it for Americans they
thought we were like tutu like too big
of [ __ ] to like have a board with
snakes on it and they thought I'd be too
scary for kids or I don't know what the
deal was I don't know if that's what the
snakes and ladders board in the movie I
don't know if that's what the actual
board looked like cuz I've never seen
one or if that was like a version that
they just did for them maybe but I just
thought that was really funny cuz I was
just like Oh snake said that's neat how
they did that for the movie and
everybody's like no it's that's what the
game is like it's not that chutes and
ladders what the [ __ ] is that
but yeah so like I said this is on to be
for free if you want to watch it it's
you know it's kind of like I don't want
to say it's like a guilty pleasure but
don't go into it think it's gonna be
like this terrifying scary movie or
anything like that it's very campy it's
very wry it's very there's like you know
they're quoting like Oscar Wilde and
[ __ ] like that it's just kind of like an
old coward play like these kind of
witticisms and all of a sudden of crap
there's just funny funny [ __ ] in it like
I said this Peter Capaldi the [ __ ]
with his bagpipes there's a mongoose in
there there's [ __ ] there's all kind
of crazy [ __ ] in this movie I'm gonna
stick with my analysis it's like an old
60s Howard Hammer horror yeah it's also
kind of like a 1970s Doctor Who yes it's
fun it's a it's a fun it also kind of
has some cowboy
feelings of like the 70s [ __ ] send bad
movies yeah when they're when they're in
the [ __ ] the the dragon's lair it
kind of looks like an underground scene
from any old British horror movie like
you know if I can it was a boy if I can
voyage to the Center of the Earth or
Sinbad or something kind of reminded me
some of the tone kind of reminded me of
a movie called the legacy never had they
run around all the rich people yeah we
did a review I was kind of like the
legacy in a sort of way but it's just
it's just a good movie and it's funny
too because like I said I feel like Ken
Russell was you know saying that he
didn't want it to be taken completely
seriously and that he made it as like
kind of to be comedic even though
because he's like well horror movie that
could encompass a bunch of different
things it's real humor though it doesn't
really come across yeah but yeah he's
like he's like I guess people he's like
it kind of became like a cult sensation
in other countries they're like an
especially really dug it in Australia
and stuff like that he's like in the UK
it's like it he's like I felt like they
wanted to take it seriously and it's
like I didn't really intend for it to be
taken seriously and he's like and I
don't understand why they didn't get it
because I mean the way this ends he's
like it's almost like the punchline of a
joke and it seemed like nobody really
got the joke was so I didn't really get
the joke well it's just that kind of the
way that they ended it with you know and
here's like I said a big spoiler alert
where you think that Peter Capaldi's
character Angus has come up with an
antidote yeah and he injects himself
with India jacks he's like oh it worked
on me blah blah blah but then you find
out like him and Hugh Grant are in the
car and then he finds out that that the
antidote like the hospital like mixed up
the antidote and they gave him something
else that wasn't anything to do with the
snake venom so that he was actually
gonna vamp out momentarily and then Hugh
Grant's like driving to the car going
man I'm fan of famished we should stop
for a bite you know at Peter Capaldi's
look and I'm like yeah I'm gonna turn
it's just kind of like I mean it was so
obviously funny at the end yeah it
didn't strike me as funny just struck me
as any any other monster movie it's like
everywhere it's like what what yeah yeah
if that's what he intended then then he
failed it was just an awesome movie he's
just off this monster movie yeah but
like I said it's it's it's goofy and
ridiculous but it's also like super fun
and it really has like a lot of really
cool I didn't really catch ridiculous
that much either in it though oh yeah
just that's just you I didn't know
that's everybody else that's true it was
just it was but that was the tone of a
lot of horror movies though then that's
true yeah though I just kind of grew up
with them being like that yeah I didn't
but to me really stand out yes anything
that special I mean you could you could
buy that measure you could also go back
and say yeah altered states was just a
big joke because it was actually kind of
like altered states it just had a little
bit more of a sexual humor to it I
thought it was like way more over the
top than altered states though like in a
self-aware kind of way you know what I
mean and it seemed like a lot more campy
maybe is because gothic was like that as
well you know it kind torch is the one
that came out right before this one
totally it kind of reminded me of that
damn serpent in the rainbow yeah see I
didn't get that either because Serpent
and the rainbow is not not super goofy
you're not funny really like oh I didn't
really think this one was that good fear
that funny I'm just saying you know I
mean maybe I but you know there's a big
difference in my sense of humor and
yours yeah I mean you laugh as [ __ ] and
I just look at you like what are you
laughing at you know I mean cuz because
it's like some high intellectual humor
about some author or something maybe you
get it you know like long but I don't
get that you know but then if I see
somebody punch somebody else in the face
I'll start laughing or somebody you know
I got like a child says humor like that
is funny to me too I mean well depending
it's like depending on who's getting
punched in the face yeah I have like a
slapstick sense of humor I like a lot of
musical humor somebody kind of you know
makes you know is they bust out singing
and it's relevant it's you know I just
had to you know yeah yeah I know what
you're talking about that's it that's
what tents like when we watch Mystery
Science Theater that tends to be hard
singing
thing that gets the biggest laugh out of
you is if they start saying they start
singing I start [ __ ] laugh like you
know because song and then they put
their own layer in there for me humor
isn't intellectual it's [ __ ] it can be
Lots all just well there's a huge I mean
that's the thing there's a huge spectrum
yeah of funny [ __ ] yeah so when I'm
watching this there was really nothing I
thought was funny I thought a lot of the
[ __ ] was now I didn't know I didn't
think it was funny I did there's
different kinds of sense I mean there
was like I said there was only thing he
was waving humor and then there was like
um you know there was self-aware like
absurdity the kind of humor - oh yeah
but I just thought its kind of you know
amusing or kind of different no when I
met the only thing that I thought was
funny out the whole movies a Hugh Grant
was pretending that the pencil was his
dick I thought that was fun on the plane
I wasn't up that wasn't what the [ __ ]
scene like he dreamed that he was on a
plane yeah and he today he was a pilot
and that like all the women in the movie
making out it had like stewardess
outfits on with like you know garters
and everything and I'm a stewardess
fantasy and then they were like rolling
around like we're like a catfight and
it's like uh and then he was like tied
up to the thing yeah I still don't get
what the symbolism of its like why a
plane why is he dressed like a pilot I
don't know it was a it's but it's just
why I I guess it's just like this buck a
weird thing that happens in the middle
and you're just like okay suppose so now
the part where he was like I the whole
part the the whole [ __ ] with him in his
like manservant or whatever I like that
that was [ __ ] funny like his his
manservant looked like he was just five
seconds away from going [ __ ] you dude
because he always like treating him like
so oh draw me a bath
do me this and the other like you know
very twee and everything and the guy
just looked like he wanted to [ __ ]
yeah I saw that but I didn't have
anything I saw that but I didn't have
any kind of motion I just I didn't think
it you know it's it's not fine and then
here grants like [ __ ] he's he's
fighting with a thing he like [ __ ]
falls over a [ __ ] drum kit
it's like they tried to make him look
like it's almost like they tried to make
him look ineffectual but they didn't
want to make him look completely
ineffectual because he did do like some
heroic [ __ ] everything although like I
said it did turn
that Angus did my sense of humor is just
to dave chappelle I wanted to say to
that Amanda Donahoe who plays the main
villain in this she was actually not the
first choice that he wanted Tilda
Swinton but he sent the script two
tildes witness she was like no next but
Amanda Donahoe she read the script and
she's like that looks like a lot of fun
if she'd been like in a [ __ ] tennis
stuff and was in a [ __ ] tennis stuff
after that but she just wanted she just
wanted the opportunity to just like go
all out and just like play this really
over-the-top villain like with all these
great outfits and like be all quippy and
everything like that so she didn't care
you can tell she's having a [ __ ]
blast like playing this role it was a
good character but yeah so like I said
it's on to be for free if you're into
cam Russell and you haven't seen it and
you kind of like vampire movies that are
not exactly vampire movies then maybe
you should go check this one out it's
actually pretty entertaining